Hey wise cracks jared again,
like everyone else.
Sometimes I just need to laugh the pain
away.
Often the crushing anxiety of existence
may feel like too much,
but hey,
that's why I have a dog.
It helps.
We are wise crack,
love us a month.
He Python,
these wildly bridge redefined comedy in
the 1970s and are still hugely
influential.
Just look at comedies today,
South Park,
rick and morty or even deadpool,
all hilarious in their own unique ways,
but without Monte python they probably
wouldn't even exist.
Monte Python paved the way for comedy as
we know it.
Combining absurdity satire and Post
Warner reflexivity and the some of the
most influential and quoted comedies
ever an x.
So because there's nothing funnier than
explaining a joke to death.
Welcome in his wise crack condition on
the legacy of Monte Python.
Oh,
and we'll be answering your questions
for the first hour and the comments.
Soap Z,
you,
they're part one postmodernism,
like a hipster and a gluten free juice
bar.
Postmodernism is everywhere these days.
Jurassic World Star Wars,
family guy.
Pretty much anything you can think of.
These films and TV shows constantly
refer back to themselves,
commenting on the narrative conventions
and iconography of their predecessors.
It's another desktop.
I wish that were the case major.
This was the death star and this is star
killer base or well just copying them
wholesale,
but nothing encapsulates this movement
more than deadpool.
Heck,
we even did an entire philosophy of on
this exact subject,
everyone loves deadpool because quite
simply he doesn't give up.
He's rebelliously self-aware,
repeatedly winking at his own narrative
and mocking the superhero genre.
Okay,
let's pro con this superhero thing.
This constant self reflexivity
encapsulates postmodernism first coined
by the French philosopher John Francois
Leotard in 1979 for Leotard.
All stories previously told fit into
off,
told grand mythologies,
great heroes on a voyage for some
grandiose goal,
or as he referred to them metanarratives
her leotard.
These metanarratives were stories that
provided a pattern and structure for
people's beliefs.
Teaching viewers a universal insight.
Think of the wizard of Oz and how when
you strip it of all the flying monkeys
and melting witches,
it's actually just a story about a girl
realizing that
there's no place like,
or even the fast and the furious
underneath all the ludicrous car stunts.
There's a deeper meta-narrative about
the importance of family through these
stories.
Morals and social customs are taught and
reinforced,
but postmodernism subverts these grand
narratives revealing the chaos and
disorder beneath,
like say Deadpool,
a comic book character who constantly
tears down everything that comic book
stand for.
You're probably thinking,
my boyfriend said this was a superhero
movie,
but that guy in the red suit just turn
that other guy into a Kebab.
But as edgy as deadpool may seem,
he ain't got shit on the pythons who
took postmodern deconstruction to a
whole other level.
Case in point there all time.
Classic Monty Python and the holy grail.
Whereas deadpool lampoons only the comic
book meta-narrative Monty Python and the
holy grail is defined by breaking down
multiple Meta narratives among them are
30 and chivalry,
Christianity logic,
and the very medium of film itself.
The first of these metanarratives are
three in chivalry.
First of all,
from the late Middle Ages,
idealizing nights as honorable and self
sacrificing.
You know,
the usual nightlys like protecting the
week,
showing mercy to enemies,
never lying and championing truth,
injustice,
but monty python and the holy grail
completely dismantles and mocks these
time tested tenant.
Who's that
when Sir Robin and counters,
a three headed giant is minstrel sing
the heroic narrative that everyone
expects.
He was not afraid to die,
but Robin himself runs the hell away as
quickly as possible.
Great.
Good.
All good.
Similarly in the Arthurian legend,
Arthur's arrival at camelot is usually
treated as an emotional high point in
his story,
comma,
Tamil.
Yet monty python undercuts the
seriousness of the moment,
turning this hallmark event into a goofy
musical number and then to top it off,
Arthur decides not to even bother going
to camelot.
No,
I'm sick and bolts.
Let's not go to camelot.
It is a silly place.
Each of our supposed great heroes are
revealed to be far less than they claim
the power hungry.
Arthur demands that every peasant
acknowledge him as their king.
No king,
but if they dare question his rule,
he immediately attacks them.
I'm being repressed.
Oh,
want to give it?
Why'd you have that Julia?
The,
that's what I'm on about sir.
Galahad the pure,
the most faithful of nights is to deuced
in less than four minutes by a company
of 160 lonely women.
And when Lancelot received a note from a
distressed maiden,
he rushes to rescue her in the process
birders dozens of unarmed people.
Then in the end,
it turns out there wasn't even a maiden
to save in the first place.
I told you I hopping on just find that
monty python users,
postmodernism to illustrate how the
stories people tell themselves enables
some awful Lancelot and Arthur's own
metanarratives justifying their violent
and oppressive acts.
The fact that these men and narratives
aren't even true to begin with is just
the icing on the cake as our nightly
heroes are revealed to be cowards,
hypocrites,
and violence.
Sociopaths.
Can you see what I mean?
I just get carried away.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Even God has put into doubt per the
Christianity meta-narrative God is good
and all powerful and has a plan for
humanity.
Yet in monty python and the holy grail,
God isn't great.
Then kind at all.
He's just a cranky Dick who's really
crappily animated philosopher Mikael
boxton define this as the downward
swing,
which I swear isn't a baseball term per
boxton.
Most stories are upward swings and that
they elevate a story,
toy,
symbolic state and make them universal.
On the contrary,
in a downward swing,
the classical story becomes so distorted
and grotesque that you don't even know
whether to scream,
cry,
or laugh,
and it's not just the story that becomes
distorted,
but also we the readers and viewers
ourselves.
Every lesson we learned through the Meta
narrative is now cast into doubt.
Right alongside it,
take one of the most famous scenes in
the holy Grail,
the witch trial,
Sir Avir,
the ys puts a poor woman through a
foolproof logic test in order to
determine if she's a witch,
her bed,
a beer which is burned at the stake,
just like wood and wood floats on water,
just like a duck.
So if the woman is a,
which he will weigh the same as a duck,
Monte Python here takes formal logic and
distorted it into a grotesque version of
itself in effect,
casting doubt on our own fundamental
faith in logic.
If classical logic can be distorted into
justifying a woman's death,
then how can it be truly trusted at all?
By the end of the Holy Grail,
this distortion extends to the very film
itself.
As Arthur prepares for an epic battle
with the French at castle ard Modern Day
police suddenly arrive in arrest of the
king for murder.
The beliefs then push and cover the
camera Lens,
breaking the fourth wall,
making the audience cognitive to the
fact they're watching a movie.
The holy grail constantly pokes fun at
itself for being a movie.
For instance,
the film's title credits or undermined
when Swedish subtitles suddenly appear
promoting the country as a terrific
vacation spot.
The credit makers are then promptly
fired,
causing the credit format to completely
change throughout the film.
Arthur Hughes's coconuts instead of
eight course due to the films tight
budget and later Arthur even refers to
one character as we'll see in 2012 and
just the hammer,
the point home,
the night's defeat,
the legendary black beast of art,
not through any battle or test of wills,
but because the anime or that design the
creature as a heart attack.
This self reflexivity reveals the holy
grail to be its own metanarrative film
just as artificial as the chivalrous are
30 in heroes with him.
Oh,
come on.
You Go.
That's just how postmodern monty python
and the holy grail truly is it
deconstructs religion and logic within a
deconstruction of heroic tropes within a
deconstruction of the film medium
itself.
Basically the inception of postmodern
phil part to the comedy of the absurd.
There's probably no show is popular on
the interwebs as rick and morty.
I mean be honest.
Wisecracks really just the domain switch
away from becoming a rick and morty fan
club and that's because the show always
ties.
It's absurd.
Humor with thought provoking insights
like well on the meaninglessness of life
as a bitch.
Take the get the episode when massive
heads suddenly appear all across the
planet,
many people begin to worship.
The head says God starting up a cult and
even sacrificing people to appease them.
Of course,
in reality,
these heads aren't gods at all,
but an alien race that just wants Earth
to participate in an American idol like
reality show.
This type of humor is known as the
comedy of the absurd.
This existential base comedy focuses on
the fallout when confronted with a world
devoid of meaning.
However,
instead of wallowing in some murky woe
is me despair.
The absurd takes the opposite approach,
pointing out the broad humor and our own
tragic insignificance.
These tragic absurdity is foundational
to Monty Python's brand of humor and
their third feature of the life of Brian
Poor.
Brian's entire existence is one big
absurd misunderstanding.
The humble peasant is born in the
stable.
Next to Jesus,
confusing the three wiseman who assumed
beaten,
not special at all.
Brian,
to be the messiah.
Here's the son of God,
King of the Jews,
Catholic.
What is it?
The projection of significance on the
insignificant is a hallmark of
existential thought.
I particular our boy Albert Kamoo,
who rejected this desperate search for
meaning and instead embraced the guest.
It absurd when Brian runs away from his
disciples,
they mistakenly believe he's risen to
heaven,
and later when Brian loses a sandal,
these same disciples per claim,
the Sandal,
his side.
Of course,
Brian didn't mean for the same old to be
anything more than footwear,
and yet people in their desire for
meaning attribute significance to even
the silliest of objects.
Will
we see this exact same misappropriation
of meaning and get swifty as principal
vagina and the rest of his colts mistake
the alien heads as gods when actually
they're only reality TV show junkies
comedies of the absurd draw their humor
from this discrepancy between what is
and what isn't between what's true and
what people believe to be true.
Characters in these absurd comedies are
often caught in hopeless situations,
forced into repetitive and ultimately
fruitless actions like Brian who
constantly tries to tell his disciples
he's not the Messiah,
but too little avail.
No matter what Brian does,
his disciples grow in number and become
ever more fervent,
all leading to a horrific and tragic
conclusion.
Crucifixion,
yet,
despite his impending doom,
Brian's comforted by his fellow
crucifixion buddies who break out into
song,
go wines.
Look on the Bra,
the Crucifixion Buddies,
cheerful lament reflects the myth of in
which poor sisyphus is Kirsch to roll a
rock up a mountain,
only for it to fall back down over and
over again.
Camou famously applied the Greek men to
life itself.
The trick though is not to let this
meaninglessness ever gets you down
instead.
In the words of life of Brian,
always look at the bright side because
when faced with our own insignificance
and impending doom,
there's only one real option.
Though it may seem completely absurd.
Laughter,
part three,
political satire.
Nowadays,
satire has become more vital than ever,
whether via late night talk shows like
full frontal with Samantha Bee or more
traditional half hour comedies like
southpark hell.
The last three seasons of Southpark
focused heavily on the 2016 election and
the trump presidency,
I don't give two shits about a treaty.
You're a Polish,
midget political satires like southpark
derive their humor by revealing the
hypocrisy in established rules and
orders.
Allow the 2016 election and the PC
brigade,
but way before South Park,
Monte Python paved the way,
subverting the established political
ideologies of England.
In fact,
southpark creators,
Trey Parker and Matt Stone often cite
Monte Python as the single biggest
influence on their show.
Matt and I met and got along so well
because we were just pure python freaks
in Monte Python's final and darkest
feature the meaning of life,
the pythons openly comment on English,
imperialism,
economic disparity,
and the classes,
social hierarchies of the country.
The opening mini movie be Crimson.
Permanent Assurance depicts a group of
poor elderly workers forced into a
pirate like frenzy by young American
yuppies.
The old workers rebelled against these
Yuppie Dick's,
throwing them out windows to their death
and then proceed to destroy every shiny
bright corporate building in their path,
bringing down the system that literally
anchored them to the ground.
The pythons carry the city miracle.
Look at capitalism throughout the film,
questioning the economic notion that
self-interest results in the greater
good.
In fact,
we see quite the opposite in the sketch,
the miracle of birth.
The doctors are far more concerned with
their fancy equipment and impressing
their administrator than the poor woman
they're operating on.
I get the most expensive machines in
case the administrator comes later in
the sketch.
Live organ transplants to bureaucrats.
Fortunately remove the liver from an
impoverished man for the good of the
country,
remarking nonsensically that they must
kill the guy that they can then take his
liver.
Met Him.
He constantly,
we see people drowning under this
system.
Britain's Yorkshire is ironically
referred to as a third world country and
in the same sketch,
a poor man is forced to sell off his
children to science in order to make
ends meet this economic disparity.
Climaxes in the sketch the autumn years
or the grotesquely obese and rich Mr
Creosote dines at a fancy restaurant
eating more and more until he literally
explodes.
The implications couldn't be clear.
The rich get richer and fatter at the
expense of the starving lower class,
but it's not just social injustice that
the python,
but the whole notion of British
imperialism in general,
the hand of God strikes down a military
officer who insists Britain will always
need an army to put down differing
ideologies and in the same sketch,
a sergeant major drills his platoon on
whether they have anything better to do.
Then march up and down the town square.
Well,
it turns out they do.
to be quite honest.
Sij I'd rather be at home with the wife
and kids now.
Yes,
Taj,
right off you go
like read a book or go to the movies or
really anything at all.
The pythons even state this central
thesis at the end of the picture.
I'm trying to be nice to people to avoid
eating fat.
Read a good book every now and then.
Get some walking in and try and live
together in peace and harmony with
people of all creeds and nations.
For the pythons.
British imperialism is a threat to the
meaning of life.
This manifests in their depiction of war
where soldiers attempting to celebrate a
birthday our gun down one by one,
the brutal reality of war of supposed
imperial conquests juxtaposed against
the simple pleasure of enjoying a
birthday cake.
These ideas extended their sketch show
the flying circus.
The show often portrays bureaucrats is
buffoons or as sticks in the mud
constantly censoring the show itself.
Pet was to my nine of inquiry feathers.
She's getting to city.
It's silly.
It's silly,
it's silly,
right?
Get on with it.
Get on with this.
For hitchens,
one set,
the essential founding gag of monty
python is the bubbling magma of
absurdity that lay beneath the fragile
crust of British reserve.
At any moment,
a man with a bowler hat or an umbrella
might become a raging crossdresser or
barking savers.
It's this unpredictability,
this mixture between the postmodern,
the political and the absurd that makes
Monte Python unlike any comedy troop
that came before or after.
By merging together social commentary,
existential angst and just plain old
silliness.
The pythons always keep you on your
toes.
They defied convention.
Concocting a brand of comedy,
so singular that a word has been created
just for that pythonesque today.
Their brand of humor permeates every
facet of the comedic landscape.
As always.
Thanks for watching guys.
Peace.
Hey everyone,
y'all know this already but I never get
tired of saying it here.
Wise crack.
We live for your feedback after our last
video about rick and morty and bojack
horseman,
a lot of you guys reached out to us and
send us some really heartfelt messages
and some really insightful emails.
It was really awesome.
We love hearing from you guys and you're
the reason why we're doing this,
so keep it coming.
We love engaging with you all and if you
like what we do have,
another way you can support us is by
becoming a patron patrons.
Get access to a growing library of
exclusive content that includes wise
crack addition,
extra our behind the scenes podcast
series with our writers,
directors and researchers.
These are deep dives into your favorite
wise crack videos like the matrix of
Lucian's,
the Emoji movie,
nihilism and rick and morty and bojack
horseman,
Captain America Civil War,
and more so to get access to the wise
crack condition,
extra podcast,
and whole bunch of other patron
exclusive content.
Click here to become a patron or follow
the link in the description.
Thanks so much for watching y'all.
Be sure to keep reaching out.
Be sure to keep emailing us,
tell us what you're thinking.
We appreciate it.
All.
Love hearing from you.
Thanks guys.
Peace.